[Applaudissements]
le look est très bon le look est très
bon c'est magnifique c'est surtout que
bon on pensait à malmédy légales ont
tourné sa famille de moteurs s'il avait
un peu de silence autour du score des
agresseurs club histoire diakité
[Musique]
donc c'est des questions sur tous les
clubs j'ai des questions et la
vérification en images tout le monde
peut jouer ici le public tout le monde
écoute et première question à 12 ans
clovis cornillac a fait sa première télé
sa toute première dans quelle émission
est ce que c'était est ce que c'était a
le bachelor dp précoce est ce que c'est
et b une image 3 sont où est-ce que
c'était ses midis première parce que
c'est une image image 3 sont tellement
il doit répondre bah dis donc c'est
celle qu'on connaît pas une ride une
image 314 celle qu'on connaît pas c'est
en 1981 que vous allez braila la coupe
de justin bieber n'a eu à pama la crise
cardiaque a indiqué la police
doulaye ming j'aimais bien les choses
bizarres l'expérience on peut quoi quand
on fait parce que clovis là c'était quoi
ça c'est quoi cette mission bah en fait
je m'en souvenais pas et c'est juste
quelqu'un marot montrer ça parce que
maintenant on retrouve tous avec sera
l'année des trucs talent et la
technologie internet est alors je
pourrais très sincère je me souviens
plus très bien si ce n'est que je me
souviens que j'étais allé parce que
c'était un pote à moi car dugowson qui
est un musicien réalisateur aime ça
maintenant on a le même âge et il était
invité dans cette émission ils m'ont
demandé est ce qu'il y avait un copain
de ça et on s'était retrouvé à faire et
alors je me souviens plus franchement
voilà 2 2 mais c'était je pense que
c'est déjà une émission qui déjà à
l'époque n'existait pas je crois que ça
c'était très calme l'ag mais le moment
le plus solide là c'était la folie a ce
moment la version sl qu'il fallait
deuxième question rapidement clovis a
joué un rôle dans une célèbre série télé
oui oui mais laquelle
c'est à la barre où il joue un caïd est
ce que ces bébés julie lescaut il joue
un coiffeur visagiste de véronique
genest
ou est ce que c'est c'est louis la
brocante aux jo avec une commode louis
saez bien sûr c'est navarro bien sûr
regardé au sein caïd attention
on t'a pas surfer qui pour carnage de
l'autre soit de vie s'était fait un peu
dans la police on attendait un sa visite
tu savais que je ne vais pas avec toi je
pense que dans pratiquement toutes les
séries des années 80 90 où les comédiens
actuelle obama moi j'ai fait tous les
méchants les acculer de savoie et qui
avait besoin de quelqu'un comme ça à
fait candidat il est lire merci cavic au
bateau
maintenant on va jouer pour la première
fois aux jeux de la fin c'est très
simple eric naulleau et komis cardiaque
je vous explique
chaque jour vous allez l'avoir 30
secondes pour classer des personnalités
j'aimerais a laissé filer fait rentrer
bien sûr fait rentrer et vous allez
jouer également si vous allez devoir
classer ces cinq personnalités télé
c'est à dire denis brogniart mimie mathy
mika david pujadas et karine le marchand
du plus petit au plus grand d'accord je
n'y allais taille
oui détails exacts ans dont vous allez
vous levez vous avez 30 secondes et
chaque jour on jouera ce sera du plus
jeune au plus vieux dieu celui qui fait
le moins l'eau dans celui qui fait le
plus d'audience
attention vous avez 30 secondes et ce
sera ça comptera pour le classement de
fin d'année avec le nid préscolaire je
vous le dis donc vous mettez 5 4 3 2 1
selon vasco penser mais remonte le petit
au plus grand d'ailleurs quand on
apprend pas ta voix n'ont cessé au coeur
de ces partis 30 secondes séparent plus
petit au plus grand
duplus faty donc la cinquième la
cinquième but le coach fera pour vous
c'est mimi c'est la plus grande donc
d'accord
mais j'allais m'y attendais donc en
changer
alors vite
jérémy libye mation 1 c'est bien david
pujadas 1 m 65 en deux et s'effectueront
en troisième position avec 1 m 73
c'est karine c'est karine le marchand et
oui c est après mika un mètre 91 et
denis brogniart à un mètre 95 il ya donc
une erreur
vous n'êtes donc pas qualifié pour la
fin d'année malheureusement voilà qu'au
mr n'y avait que l'on perde
vous l'aviez vous autour de la table
mais oui mais voilà et ben voila balayé
père dit merci à clovis cornillac
d'abord est un des clous de l'historia
qu on retrouve dès demain dans la
contrebasse
et bien sûr eric naulleau ça balance à
temps il fait samedi à 17h50 juste à la
centaine et c'est nous et naulleau c'est
le vendredi
c'est pas la première version qu'ils
abattent à coups merci
fuji qu'avec ces familles les balcons en
bois merci